hi I'm Erik Bosse and of interest
infinity war shocked us all with a
villain so Pierce said no Avenger could
ever truly take him down Red Skull yes
by the way Red Skull makes a cameo in
infinity war which isn't really a
spoiler nearly two weeks after the movie
came out but obligatory spoiler warning
for the spoilery discussion ahead yes it
wasn't enough for infinity war to end
with Thanos succeeding and snapping half
the universe out of existence
they've reminded us that Red Skull the
villain from the first Captain America
film it's still alive now he's stuck at
a crappy job on a desolate planet with
no friends but still you know that's one
less win on the board Red Skull is one
of the biggest questions people have had
coming out of the movie so let's break
down what's going on here and the deeper
meaning of his role in infinity war and
let's start with a quick reminder of goo
Red Skull even is in Captain America the
First Avenger Red Skull was known as
Johann Schmidt played by Hugo Weaving
Schmidt was an egomaniacal scientist
working for the Nazis who was obsessed
with becoming a superior being
before Abraham Erskine used his Super
Soldier Serum on Steve Rogers to turn
him into Captain America he used a rough
draft of it on Schmidt giving him this
same super strength and agility but
deforming his appearance or upgrading it
depending on what your tastes are
Schmidt was also obsessed with Norse
mythology obtaining the tesseract a
magical object that he said was from
Odin's vault using it to supercharge his
weapons and tried to lead Hydra not the
Nazis to rule the world now the
tesseract we later learned contained the
space stone one of these six Infinity
stones that Thanos uses to fulfill his
evil dreams but with Red Skull during
his fight with Captain America he picks
up the tesseract which opens a rift in
space and appears to disintegrate him
into the cosmos done and done but wait
here he is an infinity war
crashing Thanos's take your daughter to
death day this is it Hugo Weaving by the
way this is actor and talented
impressionist Ross Marquand filling in
but how did Red Skull even get here red
skulls explanation is cryptic at best
he tells Thanos a lifetime ago I do set
the stones they didn't have one in my
hands but it's cast me out
banished me here guiding others to a
treasure I cannot possess and I'm no
Marquand
so rather than frying him to bits like
we thought the space stone transported
red skull here to war mirror we actually
started to wonder whether he still might
be alive in the infinity war prelude
comic which replayed that moment from
Captain America but included this
interesting sound effect Oh
which to me is exactly what it sounds
like when someone gets teleported also
rewatching the scene for the movie that
beam that transports Red Skull looks a
lot like the Bifrost that Thor and
Heimdall used to teleport from planet to
planet and that leads us to the next
question what is Red Skull doing here
Red Skull is now these stone keeper kind
of like that old Templar night in the
cave at the end of Indiana Jones in the
Last Crusade his obsessive pursuit of an
infinity stone led him to guard one that
he can never use himself his word
suggests that the Infinity stones
themselves deemed Red Skull unworthy
that they possess some divine insight
and judgment now if we assume red skulls
teleportation was Bifrost powered
perhaps this judgment came from Odin
himself this could be part of some
protective magic that Odin cast on the
tesseract space stone or the soul stone
either way red skull has been chillin
here on Boromir for 70 years which is
interesting because it means that either
the magic of the Infinity stone prevents
him from aging or it means that that
Super Soldier Serum is a lot more
potency than we thought perhaps gonna
outlive everybody the most interesting
takeaway here is that the Infinity
stones carry their own kind of wisdom
that wisdom spoke through the mine stone
to warn vision about Thanos's approach
it spoke through the time stone to warn
dr. strange about their 14 million to
one odds and the one pathway to victory
actually check out my other video for
more details on that
maybe that wisdom also considered Thanos
worthy of succeeding so long as the
Wright murders were erased with the snap
allowing the bright survivors to avenge
them I'm sure we'll get a sense of the
cosmic implications of all this as time
goes on but in this case that wisdom
prevented red skull from possessing the
soul stone himself which leads us to her
final question what is the deeper
meaning of red skulls roll now for mini
comic nerds who watched infinity war red
skulls initial appearance struck a
familiar tone he appears hooded and
floating and spooky very Grim Reaper II
for a second you may have thought this
was death in the Infinity Gauntlet
comics mistress death is Thanos's love
interest he does everything for her she
doesn't appear in this movie but I think
there's a reason for this fake out here
Red Skull taken on the form of death
hints that this whole scene is meant for
us to examine Thanos his motives to look
deeply at his moral character after Red
Skull explains that the soul stone
demands a sacrifice of that which you
love Gamora mistakenly chides Thanos
saying he failed because he loves no one
but sadly for her she's wrong Thanos
does
someone gamora red skull by comparison
cannot possess his own because he truly
doesn't love anyone else so in a sense
red skull exists in this movie to serve
as a foil for us to compare Thanos to
the villains of the MCU past the movie
does something similar in the opening
scene with Thanos killing Loki
suggesting that Thanos is not conflicted
by his loyalties to family the precise
way that this past villain was Stannis's
goal to protect people from themselves
really isn't that different from the
goal of Ultron who also gets brought up
in this movie Ultron's greatest flaw was
hubris to need to create new life in his
own image an Android of living tissue
vibranium in the mine stone his efforts
eventually led to vision who ultimately
did him in unlike Ultron Thanos never
falls into that trap he's purely a
purifier preserving life by thinning the
herd he never kills her tortures anyone
he doesn't have to so Red Skull
completes this whole comparison to past
the villains Red Skull never loved
anyone as is the case for many villains
to the MCU
but Thanos does and that love makes him
worthy in the eyes of the universe to
achieve his goals and worthy in our eyes
to be the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
greatest game-changer but I'll throw it
over to you guys how do you think Red
Skull could ever return in a future MCU
movie comment down below with your
theories or tweet me directly at EF
Allen new rockstars on Twitter for
updates on our videos like and share
this video and subscribe in the
rockstars burg all of our deep dives and
analyses of Avengers infinity war thanks
for watching and now it's time for me to
return to my home planet
BuChE BuChE why isn't it working